how you can say that is not gain a
function it is not it's a dance and
you're dancing around this
is because you're trying to observe a
responsibility possible no one's saying
that
it is paused whether you call that game
of function whether you don't call that
gain of function
we shouldn't have been funding this
institute in the first place
yesterday there was this big exchange
between rand paul and anthony fauci
the left has declared that that anthony
fauci won this exchange
and the right has declared that rand
paul won this exchange the entire
exchange
is over the question of whether the
national institutes of health
funded research in wuhan that could have
led to the
creation of the covet 19 virus
it is unclear at this point whether that
is true or not what is true
is that the united states via the nih
funded a place called eco health
alliance which then gave a grant
to the wuhan institute of virology they
were supposed to pledge not to engage in
gain of function research
but the question is what is gain of
function research
so there are a couple of different
definitions of gain of function research
that have been utilized one particular
definition suggests that gain of
function research
is a gain of function within viruses
that already apply to humans
another definition of gain of function
research is is a is a gain of function
for an animal virus that now is made
transmissible to humans
that's what this really comes down to is
a little bit of semantic word play here
now
nothing has been we still don't know
that this came from a lab league right
it is very likely at this point that it
came from a lab leak but we still don't
know
and we don't know exactly how that virus
was developed so a lot of this is
speculative
however it is certainly worth
questioning whether the united states
scientific community should have been
paying the wuhan institute of virology
at all considering that we have no way
of actually seeing what it is that they
are doing
so here is rand paul and anthony fausch
going at it yesterday
dr falchi as you are aware it is a crime
to lie to congress
section 1001 of the u.s criminal code
creates a felony and a five-year penalty
for lying to congress
on your last trip to our committee on
may 11th
you stated that the nih has not ever and
does not now fund gain and function
research in the wuhan institute of
virology
and yet gain of function research was
done entirely in the wuhan institute
by dr xi and was funded by the nih
i'd like to ask unanimous consent to
insert into the record the wuhan
virology paper entitled
discovery of a rich gene pool of bat
sars related coronaviruses
please deliver a copy of the journal
article to dr fauci
in this paper dr she credits the nih
and lists the actual number of the grant
that she was given by the nih
in this paper she took two bat
coronavirus
genes spike genes and combine them with
a sars related backbone
to create new viruses that are not found
in nature
these lab created viruses within to
shown to replicate in humans
these experiments combine genetic
information from different coronaviruses
that infect
animals but not humans to create novel
artificial viruses able to infect human
cells
viruses that in nature only infect
animals
were manipulated in the wuhan lab to
gain the function
of infecting humans this research fits
the definition
of the research that the nih said was
subject to the pause in 2014 to 2017
a pause in funding on gain of function
but the nih failed to recognize this
defines it a way and it never came under
any scrutiny
dr richard e bright a molecular
biologist from rutgers described this
research in wuhan as
the wuhan lab used nih funding to
construct
novel chimeric sars-related
coronaviruses
able to infect human cells and
laboratory animals
this is high risk research that creates
new
potential pandemic pathogens potential
pandemic pathogens that exist
only in the lab not in nature
this research matches these are dr
ebright's words
this research matches indeed epitomizes
the definition of gain of function
research done entirely in wuhan
for which there was supposed to be a
federal pause
dr fauci knowing that it is a crime to
lie to congress
do you wish to retract your statement of
may 11 where you claimed that the nih
never funded gain of function research
in wujon
senator paul i have never lied
the question is pretty simple right
there okay so the question is
it's pretty obvious that we did actually
fund the wuhan institute of virology
that we said don't engage in gain and
function research but that we gained our
own definition of gain of function
research and so what you're about to
hear about you respond
is sort of the bill clinton it depends
on the definition of the word
is defense now from a legal perspective
he may be right right it may be why he
is going to avoid any sort of you know
criminal liability for example
because gain of function research can be
defined in a couple of different ways
on the one hand you can define gain of
function research as taking
animal viruses and mixing them with
other viruses in order to create human
pathogens
but there's a definition of gain of
function research that says really only
human viruses that are made more deadly
or more transmissible
only that is gain of function research
so that's the game that we're now going
to play it's a semantic game but the
underlying facts are really not in
dispute josh rogan
who is a columnist for the washington
post says rand paul is right
the nih was funding gain of function
research in wuhan but the nih pretended
it didn't meet their gain of function
definition
to avoid their own oversight mechanism
so here you're going to hear fauci get
very angry and play
word games here he goes
microphone your microphone senator paul
i have never lied
before the congress and i do not retract
that statement this paper that you were
referring to
was judged by qualified staff up and
down the chain
as not being gained a function
let me finish take an animal virus and
you increase the transability to humans
right you're saying that's not gain a
function yeah that is correct
and and senator paul you do not know
what you are talking about
quite frankly and i want to say that
officially
you do not know what you are talking
about
okay you get one person that's read from
the ni
function this is your definition that
you guys wrote
it says that scientific research that
increases the transmitting about
transmissibility among animals is gain
of function
they took animal viruses that only occur
in animals
and they increase their transmissibility
to humans how you can say that is not
gain a function it is not it's a
dance and you're dancing around this
because you're trying to obscure
responsibility
for four million people dying around the
world from a pandemic
and let's let's send doctor i have to
well now you're getting into something
if the point
that you are making is that the the
grant that was funded
as a sub award from eco health to wuhan
created sars kovi 2. that's where you
are getting
let me finish we don't know wait a
minute
but all the evidence is pointing that it
came from the lab and there will be
responsibility for those who funded the
lab
including yourself i totally this
community will allow the witness to
i totally resent the lie that you are
now propagating
senator because if you look at the
viruses
that were used in the experiments that
were
given in the annual reports that were
published in the literature
it is molecularly impossible no one's
saying though
it is caused it is molecularly those
virus caused the pandemic what we're
alleging is
that gain of function research was going
on in that lab and nih funded it
that is get away from it it meets your
definition and you are
obfuscating the truth i'm not
obfuscating the truth you're the one i'm
expired but i will allow the witness to
let me just finish i want everyone to
understand
that if you look at those viruses and
that's judged by
qualified virologists and evolutionary
biologists
those viruses are molecularly impossible
pause the pandemic we're saying they are
gain of function viruses because there
were animal viruses
that became more transmissible and human
and you funded it
and you admit the truth and you implying
paul your time has expired and i will
allow witnesses who come before this
committee to respond
and you are implying that what we did
was responsible for the deaths of
individual
i totally resent that and if anybody is
lying here
senator it is you
okay so what are they actually fighting
about what they're actually fighting
about is definitions and fungibility of
money
so what is gain of function research
rand paul is saying gain of function
research is
you take an animal virus you make it
transmissible to humans that's gain of
function
fauci is saying legally speaking really
it's only if you take a human virus and
make it more transmissible or more
deadly
that's gain of function that's a stupid
semantic game what we care about is
whether the united states
was in fact funding development of
viruses from animals
to humans that could have been
transmissible and deadly to other humans
right whether you call that game of
function whether you don't call that
gain of function that is a bad thing for
the united states to be doing especially
at an institute
where there had been repeated reports of
lab leaks at an institute where the
safety
concerns were serious and under the
auspices of a government
that is fascistic and communist in
nature
okay that's question number one question
number two is that the paper that rand
paul is citing to talk about
how they have been using animal viruses
in order to make them transmissible to
humans
that paper uses a specific subset of
viruses that it's investigating
and fauci is saying those viruses in
that paper
are not covid 19. the viruses in that
paper are molecularly impossible to be
covered 19.
and paul is saying i'm not saying that
the ones in this paper are covet 19.
i am saying this type of research could
have created coven 19 and that could
have leaked and we should have been
firing
we shouldn't have been funding this
institute in the first place
paul has the better of this argument he
does that doesn't mean that legal
liability is going to be attaching to
anthony fauci or that anthony fauci is
guilty
of some sort of perjury because perjury
requires an
intent to lie and it also requires that
you be legally untrue
and that's arguable and again found you
sort of living in this gray space here
what it does mean is that the united
states's complicity in working
with the wuhan institute of virology
could create a
significant level of moral culpability
for the us government
we should not be working with scientific
institutions that run under the auspices
of terroristic governments and i'm sorry
the chinese government is a terroristic
government
it just took over hong kong and is
currently arresting editorial members of
apple daily
right now it is threatening taiwan
it is threatening the globe in a wide
variety of ways
ranging from internet surveillance
to belt and road connections to
funding of infiltrating groups in the
west
you know this is this is where rand paul
is exactly right
and the fact that we aren't willing to
look this in the face is pretty ugly
and what this really comes down to in
the end is how we see china
and until the united states starts
recognizing that china is an enemy the
chinese government is an enemy
not the chinese people the chinese
people have been subjected to tyranny
since
the the rise of mao the chinese
government is an enemy to the united
states and funding that enemy and
interacting with the enemy of the gover
this governmental entity is an insane
abdication of responsibility and that is
a bipartisan abdication of
responsibility does not live
in one party i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the ben shapiro show if you
did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button so you stay up to date with all
our future content